Tu hija, que ya has llevado tanto en ti, querrá saber
qué trajiste, qué regalaste, qué luz no dejaste apagar.
Cuando vinieron a buscar víctimas en la noche,
¿dormías o te despertaste?
¿Cuál fue el precio de estar despierta?
¿En el año que dijimos se acabó, qué hiciste con tu privilegios?
¿Cenaste en la miseria de los demás?
¿Desviaste la mirada o miraste la llama?
¿Sabías de tu habilidad o la trataste como pasividad?
¿Te dejaste engañar por los epítetos de "desagradable" o "menos que"?
¿Enseñaste con un corazón abierto o un puño cerrado?
¿Dónde estabas?
Dile la verdad. Hazla tu vida.
Confirmarla. Di, "Hija, yo estaba allí
con el momento dibujado en mi cara como una daga,
y la arrojé a sí mismo,
rebanando espacio para ti".
Dile la verdad, cómo viviste, a pesar de las malas probabilidades
Dile que eras valiente,
y siempre, siempre en compañía de valor,
casi todos los días cuando solo te tenías a ti misma.
Dile que nació como tú,
como sus madres antes, y sus hermanas,
en la era de las leyendas, como siempre.
Dile que nació justo a tiempo,
justo a tiempo
para liderar.
(Aplausos)